We certainly choose each other for self
awareness and consciousness and
intelligence,
and I don't know if you're,
if you're choosing a mate,
there's an arms race in human beings.
We're choosing intelligent mates.
Especially that's especially the case
for women in relationship to men.
So,
um,
so that,
the idea that that's a choice.
Well,
that's partly why it's even that makes
himself conscious in the garden of Eden,
right?
She offers them the apple.
She's the one that makes him self
conscious and I think that's actually
accurate because the evidence from the
evolutionary biologists is that human
sexual female sexual selection was what
are the driving factors that
differentiated us from chimpanzees.
It's a major factor.
Chimpanzee females are not selective
maters.
They go into estrus,
they'll mate with anything.
What happens is the dominant males
chased the subordinate males away and so
they end up leaving more offspring,
but it's not a consequence of selection
on the part of the females in human
beings.
It's completely different.
Concealed ovulation and intense
selection pressure from women on men.
You have twice as many female ancestors
as you have male ancestors and people
could never have have a hard time
working that out arithmetically,
but it's not that problematic.
You just think on average,
every woman had one child,
half of men had none,
and the other half had to.
And that's approximately correct if you
average across the entire history of
human sexuality.
So human males in particular are subject
to a vicious selection,
pressure on the part of females,
and I also think that's partly why
nature is represented symbolically as
female among human beings,
because after all,
nature is what selects.
There's no better definition of the
nature then that which selects.